notre sujet on disait le président veut
tourner la page c'est très clairement
c'est qu'il montre ce qu'il veut mais
non les Français ça leur reste en
travers de la gorge j'entendais qu'à
l'Elysée en disait ok bon toute façon on
va arrêter le les mesures salées on va
passer au sucre mais c'est un peu comme
si les gens avaient fait n'avaient pas
supporté le plat de résistance qui
faisait une grosse indigestion et qu'on
leur disait et maintenant le dessert et
non en fait on a plus faim c'est trop
tôt on veut faire une pause et donc le
fait de voir le président comme ça tout
le temps tous les jours même s'il leur
annonce que on est passé au dessert et
bien ça ne passe pas et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui la popularité du
président elle est elle est faible enfin
il y a 70% de mauvaises opinions 30% de
bonnes opinions ça ça n'a pas encore
le baromètre c'est c'est moi par mois
sur ce niveau de popularité ça bouge pas
là ça fait beaucoup baisser le mois
dernier il entendu six points il a perdu
11 points depuis l'annonce de la réforme
des retraites pour Elisabeth borne elle
a perdu plus vite du terrain et là elle
stagne ce sont des niveaux bas
et derrière cela alors on rentrera sans
doute dans le détail tout à l'heure mais
on voit qu'il y a beaucoup de
qualificatifs alors on peut retenir un
extrêmement sévère quand même qui
ressort et ça faut que vous nous
détailler effectivement le résultat sur
ce trait d'image spécifiquement voilà
c'est à dire que il est dynamique ça les
Français le disent 55% il est dynamique
mais ils sont 65% à dire c'est quelqu'un
de brutal c'est 16 points de plus depuis
son élection ça veut dire que sur un an
on est bien d'accord excusez-moi et là
c'est sur un an ça veut dire que c'est
déjà quelque chose qui lui était quand
même attribué c'est-à-dire le fait que
ce soit quelqu'un qui passe en force
mais cette réforme des retraites c'est
vraiment le symbole de la une forme que
l'on passe au forceps que l'on impose il
y a aussi un autre attribut qui est le
fait que les Français considèrent qu'il
n'est pas ouvert au dialogue 80% des
Français le disent et c'est vrai qu'il a
beau lui aller sur le terrain en disant
vous vous bouchez les oreilles mais en
fait à la au départ c'est à lui qu'on
reproche cela qui est intéressant on y
reviendra en détail sur ces autres
traits de d'image Mathieu Suker historic
si on prend un peu de de recul
historiquement de toute façon on le sait
bien les réformes des retraites la
rendent rarement l'exécutif populaire
mais est-ce qu'il y a là une dimension
supplémentaire justement avec vous
l'évoquiez cet empilement de d'outils
d'efficacité constitutionnelle on
pourrait appeler ça comme ça qui sont
tous légaux mais qui ont été qui se sont
succédés est-ce que est-ce que il y a il
y a ce cran supplémentaire dans
j'allais dire la détestation c'est
peut-être un peu fort mais on en est pas
loin je crois pas que ce soit fort
justement le pouvoir est à l'école d'un
popularité donc de ce point de vue là il
n'y a pas de surprise il y a pas de
nouveautés alors l'impopularité d'une
première ministre ou d'un président de
la République ça vaut pas la même chose
parce qu'une première ministre on peut
la remercier et la remplacer donc c'est
pas un problème insoluble d'un
popularité à Matignon l'impopularité à
l'Elysée c'est plus compliqué et même si
pour le coup il y a des précédents en
matière de d'un popularité et de
défiance et même on a tous ressorti les
cotes concernant Nicolas Sarkozy
François Hollande etc il y a eu parfois
pire que Emmanuel Macron il y a
effectivement une spécificité qui
concerne Emmanuel Macron il y a la
défiance mais il y a la défiance avec la
longévité c'est-à-dire que les niveaux
de défiance atteints par ces
prédécesseurs c'était en deuxième partie
de quinquennat en deuxième partie de
mandat et à l'approche d'un rendez-vous
démocratique qui était la future
élection présidentielle là le problème
c'est que on ne fête pas le premier
anniversaire de Macron à l'Élysée mais
le sixième anniversaire d'Emmanuel
Macron on les disait donc le niveau de
défiance il intervient beaucoup plus tôt
que d'habitude et par ailleurs si on
compare simplement avec son prédécesseur
c'est une défiance qui ne génère pas
comme avec François monde dont la
présidence était dite normale où en fait
très horizontale par rapport à celle
d'Emmanuel Macron François Hollande
quand ça marchait l'opinion le
considérait comme plutôt sympathique
alors je sais pas si c'est une qualité
qui est importante pour un chef d'État
mais les gens le trouvaient plutôt sympa
parce qu'il ressemblait à tout le monde
et puis quand ça s'est inversé les gens
ont trouvé à tort ou à raison nul et du
coup le sentiment suscité c'est du
mépris c'est ce que j'allais dire alors
je ne sais pas ce qu'il vaut mieux
choisir entre le mépris la détestation
mais on voit bien que dans le contexte
en tout cas la détestation que la
présidence ultraverticule et ultra
verticale d'Emmanuel Macron suscite à
quelque chose de d'inédit et de
dangereux
[Musique]